If you're about to give a speech and
seconds before you're sat down reviewing
your notes frantically to try to
remember what it is you're going to talk
about before standing in front of the
group,
I'm telling you now there's a better
way.
In this video, I am going to break down
what you should be doing in the weeks,
the days, the hours, the minutes, and
the seconds before you give a speech.
What should you focus on in the weeks
leading up to your speech? This is your
time to build. And I'm a big fan of
five-point speech structures. So, simply
put, a five-point speech structure
includes an introduction, point number
one, point number two, point number
three, and then a conclusion. And what's
important about the introduction is that
you say something in the first few
seconds of your speech that's going to
capture the audience's attention. What
people do far too often is give general
formalities. Hi there, for anyone who
doesn't know me, my name is Wade.
You don't need to do that. Instead, you
can jump right into a story, give a
surprising fact, or ask a
thought-provoking question.
From there, you build your speech into
three chunks. And often this works well
if you have stories for each of the
general themes or ideas. And the reason
that works well is you don't have to
rely so much on notes that you would
read in front of an audience because
that eliminates body language and vocal
variety. And then the idea with the
conclusion is that it makes your speech
come full circle. So, whatever the first
thing you mentioned was is how you end
it as well by mentioning that once
again. So, in the weeks leading up to
your speech and perhaps the months you
really want to focus on building a
structure that you're comfortable with.
In the days leading up to your speech,
this is your time to practice.
Practice is so incredibly important and
what I would suggest is 1 week out from
the day you give your speech, plan to
practice that speech every single day.
So what this will mean is that minimum
you're going to have seven practice reps
before you actually stand in front of a
room and give a speech. Because when we
stand in front of a room for the first
time, it's daunting looking at all the
faces that are sitting so close to us
and we can feel overwhelmed especially
if we haven't gone through the process
of practicing that speech. But if we've
already practiced that speech seven
times that week,
now it's not the first time we're going
through it, it's the seventh. And you
can even start this a few weeks in
advance. But definitely the week leading
up to your speech, I want you every
single day to do a run-through and
practice that speech. Here's what to do
in the hours leading up to your speech.
I want you to get to the venue early.
If you're part of a Toastmasters club,
come to the room that you do your
Toastmasters meetings at if you're
giving a speech that day and stand in
the spot you're going to be giving the
speech and get used to the vantage point
of the room.
No one will be sitting down yet.
Hopefully you're the first one at the
meeting, but you can visualize yourself
doing the speech well and start to
imagine once that room does fill up
where people are going to be sitting and
and practice your intro and get familiar
with the space.
This will give you a lot of confidence
when you actually go to deliver the
speech.
And this goes beyond Toastmasters. If
you're giving a speech at a big
conference,
get to that conference early. If they
have the option for a mic check,
absolutely go and do the mic check. Get
yourself familiar with your voice being
amplified. If there's going to be
lighting that's shooting on the stage,
get used to what that lighting is going
to feel like when you're standing there.
And again, get used to the environment.
If it's a wedding that you're giving a
speech at,
that's a little trickier. You're
probably not going to be the first one
at the wedding venue, but if you do get
a chance before your speech and you know
where you're going to be speaking,
just to yourself casually, as you're
talking to other people, stand in that
spot and look out at the area. Get
familiar with the different tables and
how people are sat. And nobody will know
what you're doing. You're just standing
there looking at the room, but start to
think and visualize how you will do that
speech well.
But by standing in front of the room in
advance of your speech, it's going to
give you a lot more confidence for when
you actually start. So, you're about to
give a speech in a few minutes. What
should you be doing?
Well, if it's a bigger conference or
some form of event where there's a lot
of attendees,
one thing I would encourage you to do is
to stand.
So, find a spot at the side of the room
and be standing up. Just off to the
side. And assuming that there's a lot
more chairs and everyone is facing the
stage where you're going to be
presenting,
it's your chance to stand off to the
side and get ready for the speech you're
about to do. Because when you're
standing, that is your body getting
ready for action.
It's a lot easier to start a speech when
you're already standing than to go from
sitting down to then standing up
afterward.
And the same can be true for a
Toastmasters meeting, although you're
probably not going to do this too many
minutes in advance. It might only be a
few seconds before you give your speech.
But when you're standing, that is your
ability to jump right into it and to
deliver more effectively. And the other
benefit of standing in advance, again
off to the side of the room, is that you
can start to get used to the faces
and seeing where people are sitting and
getting used to this vantage point.
Because what happens if we go from
sitting at a conference and being an
attendee and watching speeches and all
of a sudden we're called up to give a
presentation,
this
subtle movement of coming up and then
beginning to speak all of a sudden
becomes really daunting. Seeing
everyone's eyes on us and that
overwhelming feeling, if we already had
some nerves, can feel
incredible.
But if you're able to stand in advance
and get used to some of those faces
already looking that way, and now the
transition isn't sitting to then being
eyes on you, but rather already sort of
being used to that, coming up and it's a
natural transition.
This might seem like a minor thing, but
I promise you this is going to make a
world of difference. Be standing up the
minutes before your speech. So, you're a
few seconds away from delivering a
speech.
What do you do?
This is the time to calm your breathing.
Many people get nervous when it comes to
public speaking. In fact, it's the
number one most common personal fear in
the world. It's known as glossophobia.
What we can do to calm ourselves is a
breathing technique. And many people are
familiar with box breathing, which is a
great option. That is inhaling for 4
seconds,
holding for 4 seconds,
exhaling for 4 seconds,
holding for 4 seconds, and repeating.
One that I like to use is the 3-second
inhale followed by a 6-second exhale,
and I do that three times. So,
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> I won't do it all three times. You get
the point.
By doing this, instantly there's a
calmness that you feel. It's regulating
your breathing. It's regulating your
heart rate.
It instantly adds that calming effect.
Do that a few seconds before you get up
there. Get control of your breath.
That's not going to eliminate the
nerves. You're still going to feel a bit
nervous, but that goes a long way in
calming yourself and allowing you to
settle in to the role of speaker. A
final thing to do a few seconds before
you give a speech
is drink some water.
You see, our mouths do some funny things
when we're speaking, and often our mouth
goes quite dry.
But, if you take a sip of water in
advance, or a few sips of water, and
really swish the water around, and also
consider having water nearby on stage in
case mid-speech you notice that dry
mouth experience happens again, that's
going to help eliminate that problem.
Because if we are speaking and we notice
this dry mouth, the audience may or may
not notice, but we certainly will as the
speaker. And if we notice it, it's going
to make us even more nervous. But the
great thing about having water on stage
is that you can casually have a sip.
And it doesn't look odd to transition
between thoughts. In fact, it actually
buys you an extra second to think. So,
take those sips of water in the seconds
leading up to your speech and consider
having water on stage with you. I hope
this video on what to do in the weeks,
days, hours, minutes, and seconds
leading up to your speech has been
helpful for you.
What did I miss? Let me know in the
comments what works for you in terms of
your pre-speech routine.
And if you are a leader or an executive
who really wants to get serious about
improving your public speaking skills
for your career development, or maybe
you have an upcoming event like a
wedding and you want to do an incredible
job for the bride and groom with your
speech,
reach out to me. I would love to work
with you on a one-on-one basis. I have a
Stan Store link below, and I have all
sorts of options there of private
lessons. I also run speaker accelerators
periodically. So, comment below this
video if you're interested in that. But
I want to thank you for taking the time
to watch this video. If you have not
already done so, subscribe to my channel
because it is my mission to make you a
more confident speaker, and I have a ton
of free content that will continue to do
just that. And check out this video that
YouTube is recommending. Thanks so much
for watching this one.